з міністра завантажених праворуч
президентів р-н
та священному дипломату франк-вальтер
штайнмайєр у так і в дало все видно ти
давала своєї кандидатури на вище
однопартійців із соціал-демократичної
партії али християнських демократів
якщо відривав їх по риму вам його волосся
на єдиним кандидатом на посаду
федерального президента не машини
правда чисел discuss the city по тайзі
регіон як їм добра ще партії про
ваблю коаліції думалося про диво кандидата
і кого храму діани нашої України
поважаєте особливо надати їм посаду і
федерального президента від трохи йому
передавала
на майданчик чорнить шинні голова fair
ньому гаук завищені було туго нудитися
на інший термін погляду навік та стан
здоров'я в результаті було відразу мило що
наступна до морального авторитету
будь-який intune nti в галку
знає і буду нелегко у продавалися тип
німецької партії, що в ході дурі думаю
quality
зустрічалася що гідного кандидата
на прикиньте живий на лідер
соціал-демократів зігмар габріель
з іншого хіт кінним і фактично
поставив перед фактом партнери з
quality
хто самий штайнмайєр мої статі з прискіпливим
кандидатом поспішаю канцлер ангела меркель
заявила що у julie wanna і на адресу
на Петро і травня кандидата
соціал-демократів у team петля тижневих
порву бурі в lido риф хдс і хсс то
степан стало відразу мило що за усмішку їм
впевненістю сама штайнмаєр уже в замку
в і дата президентського смугу хвороба
штайнмайєр candida такі штучки zara в
романі вона може чудо злодії брезентового
ти наш українець не матч і непотрібні
сильний лідер і самий тпр кулісу сил
баки втиснути популісти ефіру
дружина сумнівається у прибраний не штайнмайєра
по польщі windows вершини та дипломати
у двох німецьких у рядах успішно вчу лева
за зовнішньополітичні відомства по
інша у продавця станеш місяців винод
шульве список у люблін їх политі гинем
екшени
гіпноз актуальним досвід його не їм
штайнмаєра на посаді президента впливати
budgets сорок один вид соток німців
адже ще й саман і порох і обличчя з dp
and when ви про менш сировину знестися
через і йому довіряєш вік і видовищ
політичний до 8 бітної представляли
нашу Україну посилити і добрий виберу на
разина моє рідне
їм свої кандидатури та ціни на його
вкрасти тепер слово за федеральним і
збору маякіс кликається раз на 5 руки
вимкнена для броня федерального
президента голосування вигляд будете 2
знайти те валют його 2017 руку